everyone hates going to work at least
sometimes even if you're a Millionaire
movie star with thousands of adoring
fans once again my life has been saved
by the miracle of lasagna the story of
how comedy Legend Bill Murray ended up
voicing a lasagna loving cat in a
horrible half animated half liveaction
movie almost sounds like the plot to a
comedy film itself apparently he' had
been wanting to do a cartoon movie and
when a script came his way that appeared
to have been written by the legendary
Joel Cohen of the Cohen Brothers he
didn't look Beyond the first few pages
before signing up as Murray tells a
story it wasn't until filming was about
to begin that he learned the writer was
not Joe Cohen of the big Labowski and No
Country for Old Men Fame but actually
Joe Cohen best known for writing films
like Monster Mash the movie and Cheaper
by the Dozen at that point it was too
late to back out and Murray claims he
spent weeks in the S Booth working on
the dialogue in a futile attempt to save
both Garfield and its sequel A Tale of
Two Kitties it's definitely a cautionary
tale but now he wastes the C and
brothers would really make a Garfield
movie multiple movie contracts have been
a staple of Hollywood since the studio
system days of the 30s and 4S and
they're still quite common today even
though actors should probably know
better by now in one recent example
Shila Buff was robed into a three movie
deal for the Transformers franchise
following the second movie in the series
Revenge of the Fallen Leff wasn't shy
about his disdain for the sequel in an
interview with reporters at Canon 2010
he singled out director Michael Bay and
said I wasn't impressed with what we did
there were some really wild stunts in it
but the heart was gone we got lost mik
went so big that it became too big
unless you have those relationships then
the movie doesn't matter then it's just
a bunch of robots fighting each other
please just let me just let
me
[Music]
it can't take that guy anymore despite
the heavy derision from critics all of
the Transformers films have been bugs
off his successes particularly
internationally leur finally managed to
exit the fr franchise after the third
film Dark of the Moon and though he may
have hated the creative experience of
working on them surely the millions of
dollars he made as some witwi offer some
consolation today he might be one of the
most respected Brides actors working
appearing as the iconic Jean Luke Bard
in the Star Trek franchise and Professor
X in the X-Men movies but in the early
1980s he was practically unknown in
Hollywood though he had a role in David
Lynch's Dune in ' 84 most of his work
was still on the stage in those days and
that unfortunately left him with very
little in his pocket in fact he was so
hard up for cash that in 1985 he was
forced into a role in the ill-advised
action sequel wild geese 2 because he
was in dire need of some home repairs
according to Stewart a local contractor
priced out the desperately needed work
on his windows at 2,000 Sterling nearly
$10,000 in today's money Stuart told a
crowd at wizard ComicCon in 2010 the
next day I get a call from my agent
saying you're not going to want to do
this but you have an offer to play a
Russian colonel in wild geese 2 on his
agent told him that it paid £2,000
Stuarts had no choice but to accept
realizing that the fans in attendance
might now go looking for the movie to
mock him Stuart made sure to preface her
enjoyment by telling them just remember
it paid to replace my bay window still
one of the biggest Leading Men in
Hollywood Brad Pit came to Fame in the
early '90s after the turn of the
Millennium though pit had a few Clunkers
mixed in with his critically acclaimed
hits like 2004's Troy it's a movie he's
not particularly fond of these days nor
anything he's proud of he said in an
interview with the New York Times in
2019 I could not get out of the middle
of the frame it was driving me crazy I
become spoiled working with David finer
he's the biggest man I've ever seen I
wouldn't want to fight
him that's why no one will remember your
name but what might be most surprising
is that it's not a movie he even wanted
to make he revealed a port out of
another movie and then had to do
something for the studio so I was put
into Troy it wasn't painful but I
realized that the way that movie was
being told was not how I wanted wanted
it to be and made by own mistakes in it
he nevertheless praised director Wolf
Gang Peterson but he said he sees Troy
as a learning experience that taught him
to be intentional about the stories and
films he chooses to do I'm flesh and
blood but not
human I haven't been human for 200 years
even a decade Before Troy Brad Pit made
a movie he's not too proud of it was the
early 1990s and he was tapped to Star as
Louie in the Neo Jordan adaptation of an
riser's Gothic romance novel Interview
with the Vampire opposite Tom Cruz at
first excited to star in the film pit
said he quickly changed his mind after
struggling with excessive makeup un
comfortable contact lenses and a
difficult nighttime shoot in London in
the dead of winter not only that but
based on his knowledge of the book pit
said he assumed the movie would be all
about Louie and realized too late it was
far more centered on Cruiser's leack
character feeling like he'd been
sidelined in a passive role and dealing
with a nightmarish production pit said
he wanted out he taught Entertainment
Weekly years later I'm telling you one
day it broke me I called David geffin
who was a good friend he was a producer
and he had just come to visit I said
David I can't do this anymore I can't do
it what would it cost me to get out
unfortunately for pit he said gein's
figure was a stunning $40 million forced
to complete the film pit got through the
production which ultimately helped raise
his profile as a co-star and a wildly
popular bug off It smash Ryan Reynold's
first time as Deadpool wasn't really
something he wanted to do at least not
the way it was written on the page first
appearing in X-Men Origins Wolverine as
a MK with a mouth Reynolds had already
been signed up to do a solo Deadpool
movie so when the character was slated
to have a supporting role in Origins the
studio came to him with an offer to play
it there first he Tau Entertainment
Weekly Origins came along and it was
sort of like play Deadpool in this movie
or we'll get someone else to with that
kind of pressure Reynolds may have
feared that if he said no it would
jeopardize his deal for the Deadpool
movie unfortunately when he read the
script he wasn't happy about what he
read he felt pressured into accepting it
though telling the studio I'll do it but
it's the wrong vers version Deadpool
isn't correct in It ultimately Reynolds
was proved right the film was a flop the
version of Deadpool in the film's climax
was widely pan and it would all but niy
the notion of a Deadpool movie it
eventually took Reynolds himself leaking
some CG test footage years later to
finally get it of the ground though her
life was cut tragically short during a
boating trip in 1981 actor Natalie Wood
managed to appear in a number of alltime
Classics including Rebel Without a Cause
And Westside Story rising to fame as a
teenager when she was still in high
school she played a key supporting role
in the iconic 1956 John Ford Weston The
Searchers starring John Wayne the role
she played wasn't one that she was happy
to take though in those days actors had
few options under what was called the
studio system where actors were
contracted to a studio that put them
into pictures on their whim this system
was typically lucrative for everyone
involved but immense that actors
couldn't pick their projects in the late
1940s wood had signed a 7-year deal with
Warner Brothers and found herself placed
into Ford's film in a part she felt she
wasn't n right for these are my
people H mayor go go Martin please
feeling miscast would play Debbie
Edwards a young white woman who had been
kidnapped as a little girl and raised by
Native Americans Wayne plays Ethan
Edwards her uncle who spends years
looking for her though the movie became
one of the most beloved in the western
genre Wood's role as Debby was often
seen as a dark spot in an otherwise
great film while lamenting his part in
dogville an experimental film by
controversial writer director L vant
Tria Paul betany said he felt tricked
into the movie and forced to complete it
after he signed on he spoke about his
role in dogville in a 20111 interview
with the guardian saying he saw the
movie as an unenjoyable experience and
that he only did the film because of his
coaster stellen scars guard fipp to me
he said you're going to turn up it'll be
fantastic it's like a party all the time
but once sunet the production turned out
to be a disaster from top to bottom and
betany confronted his friend betany
recalled a conversation saying I said
stellen what were you talking about and
he said man I was making it up I just
couldn't face doing it without you
according to betany vontre was a bit of
a puppet master and willing to
collaborate with the actors still he
didn't want to be too negative about the
filmmaker admitting his Moody nature may
be why he is considered to be so
extraordinary in the early 2000s
superhero movies were booming and Lion's
gate turned to Indie comic hit Hellboy G
deloro wrote and directed the film and C
Ron pman in the title role of the demon
who becomes a government agent Doug
Jones played a sidekick the amphibious
Abe Sapien but when the movie was in
postproduction Frasier actor David Hyde
Pius was brought in to replace the voice
of Abe sapan in an effort to give the
movie a little more star power I need to
touch it to see see what past
future whatever this object holds in an
interview with CBR in 2008 Jones said
Pierce was apparently unaware that his
voice work was being used to replace him
perhaps assuming that the man in the
suit was a simple stunt person David
Hyde Pierce comes in he hears my
original performance in his earpiece he
sees my performance on the film footage
that he has to voice over and he steps
back and says why am I here to himself
Piers was already under contract though
and couldn't quit so he did his job and
left and much to the annoyance of The
film's Producers the Fraser star refused
to be credited for his performance out
of respect for Jones in the end had
muted the very reason he was hired as
his name wasn't out in front of the
movie for the sequel the studio learned
its lesson and Jones was simply allowed
to perform Abe sapen in full voice and
awe not every actor who is forced to
play a role they hate regret it such is
the case with Robert Patterson whose
part as Edward Cullen in the Twilight
films made him an international
Superstar and allowed him to be able to
pick more personal Indie projects like
High Life Cosmopolis and the lighthouse
that earned him critical Acclaim
nevertheless playing the sparkly vampire
Edward wasn't a good experience for him
in the first Twilight as the actor said
he hated his character and felt he was
at risk of being fired every day and it
was a role he was forced to continue
playing for three more movies over the
years Patterson has been candid about
his dislike for the Twilight series as
well as his critique of its author
Stephanie Meyer after reading the books
he told e some things about Edward is so
specific I was just convinced like this
woman is mad she's completely mad and
she's in love with her own fictional
creation and sometimes she would feel
uncomfortable reading this thing if it
hadn't been so successful I think people
would have thought it was really weird
it's a really weird story he heaped
plenty of hate on fans of the books and
movies too and in the DVD commentary
talked about leaving the premiere of the
first movie Midway through he also
downright hated his own character the
original Star Wars film from 1977
boasted a leading cast of Mostly unknown
actors like Mark Hamill Harrison Ford
and Carrie Fisher while it two lone big
names were British veterans Peter
Cushing and Alec Guinness in supporting
rol though Cushing was known for making
schlock horror movies for decades
Guinness was a well respected Academy
award-winning actor famous for movies
like like The Bridge on the River Quai
and dog D Zago he was a serious sespan
who resented that his role as Obi-Wan
Kenobi was where all audiences seemed to
know him from after 1977 and he hated
the role itself these aren't the droids
you're looking for these aren't the
droids we're looking
for he can go about his business calling
the dialogue rubbish and his character
unbearable he famously told a friend via
written correspondence that he didn't
enjoy making the film at all while his
co- starle said he was lovely on the set
and a joy to work with Guinness's
experience making the first movie seemed
to have been anything but Pleasant for
him but despite the poor experience the
actor was backward pricing the role for
its two sequels feeling somewhat forced
to return because of the massive payday
he knew he could demand given the
franchise's sudden popularity as a
result Guinness leveraged strict
requests and was able to at least get a
bigger salary a shorter shooting
schedule reportedly just half a day of
filming as well as a percentage of the
sequel's
profit
[Music]
for many movie goers Tyler Perry is Meda
and nothing else they don't know him for
his roles in popular dramas like gong
girl Alex Cross or vice but only for his
part as a manic grandmother featured in
more than a half dozen movies beginning
with 2005's Diary of a Mad Black Woman
the character has also appeared in
Holiday themed flicks like buo a Meda
Halloween and even an animated Adventure
inspired by Eddie Murphy's genderbending
roles in The Nutty Professor Perry told
NPR that he also created the character
to pay tribute to the older women in his
family but when it proved popular enough
to spark its own franchise Perry was
forced to keep going against his will
for decades more while doing press for
the film a fall from grace in 2020 Perry
told level it was never something I
enjoyed doing my hand to God I hated the
costume the wig all of it the
interviewer was skeptical that he could
really have hated it that much but Perry
insisted it was true even from the very
beginning the problem seems to be that
Meda became a hit he explained it ended
up being a$2 billion franchise at that
point there wasn't really an option of
saying no and he kept putting the wig
back on year after year though he
claimed during that 2020 interview he
was happy it was finally over he
returned in 2022 with a Meda homecoming
when an actor feels forced to play a
role or return to one they wanted to
leave behind it's not always for
financial or contractual reasons
sometimes it's simply a matter of
conscience a feeling of obligation not
just to the audience but to the
character themselves that's how things
went down for am Lee Curtis when she
regretting returned again as Lori stro
for a brief cameo in Halloween
resurrection a sequel to what she had
hoped would be a final appearance in
Halloween H2O 20 years later in spite of
her promise to herself that H2O would be
a final role in the series she agreed to
return for one simple reason she hated
the plans for the sequel feeling the
recck condemning of H2O ruined her
character and wanted to at least try to
do it right for the sake of the audience
in Resurrection is revealed that Strode
hadn't killed Michael Myers in the
previous film's ending a murdered an
innocent man wearing Maya's mask and
willing to leave the franchise on that
note she felt she owed it to fans to see
her character out with her definitive
death well Halloween resurrection was a
joke though she agreed to do a small
Cameo Curtis did have Wonder Man she
told producers while attending New York
ComiCon in 2022 you have to kill me in
the first 10 minutes of the movie I've
killed an innocent man and I can't live
with that Jason Bourne wasn't a role
that Matt Damon truly hated but he has
seemed to love playing the character in
The born identity and its many sequels
there is however one sole exception the
born ultimatum over the years the actor
has been extremely candid about what
went wrong placing blame on the studio
for inking screenwriter Tony Gilroy to a
bad deal which resulted in a rush to
rewrite the end result was a screenplay
Damon described as awful telling GQ it's
terrible it's really embarrassing he was
having a go basically and he took his
money and left I doubt
that why would you doubt that if you
were in your office right now we'd be
having this conversation face to face
bad script in hand the studio was forced
to massively overhaul it with just weeks
until filming was set to kick off and
Damon didn't want to do it ultimately
Damon was forced to make ultimatum
without a script he liked he may not
outright regret it though because when
it hit theaters it received rave reviews
and became the highest grossing entry in
the franchise Stanley Tui is one actor
who was forced to continue working on a
movie he didn't want to make because he
couldn't get out of his contract signed
up to play the villain in a supernatural
murder mystery The Lovely Bones Tui
admitted that he quick came to hate his
own character serial killer pedophile
and child rapist George Harvey and found
the experience of making the movie a
difficult one he told Entertainment
Weekly It's a Wonderful movie but it was
a tough experience simply because of the
role I tried to get out of playing the
role which is crazy because I needed a
job I don't want you to
leave I'm not going to hurt you Su of
course tui's attempts to back out of
playing Harvey amounted to nothing and
the actor was was forced to Soldier on
his turmoil wasn't in vain though
because he was later rewarded for his
performance with an Academy Award
nomination for best supporting actor I
did think it was have fun with it
because it's it's it's it's a very silly
kind of sule of a movie it's easy for an
actor to look back on a bad movie after
the fact and acknowledge that it was
terrible but it's another for a Star to
realize that their movie is going to be
awful while they're in the middle of
making it or worse before it even starts
production but that's just what happened
to Alec Baldwin while he was working on
the 2012 flop Rock of Ages a jukebox
musical comedy featuring the songs of
80s rock greates like de leopard Guns
and Roses Joan Jet Twisted Sister and
Pat benitar he said in an interview with
Van f a week in you go oh god what have
I done the plane is buffeting the engine
is on fire Baldwin said he initially
signed up to be able to work with
director Adam shankman and appear with
Styles like Tom Cruz and Russell Brand
but he immediately had second thoughts
and asked out of his contract reports at
the time cited a possible medical
condition for his attempt to leave the
film but the actor now seems to admit
that the real reason was that he simply
didn't want to make the movie which he
called a total disaster though he hopes
the studio would let him out of his deal
that never happened and Baldwin was
forced to complete It Rock of Ages
received midling reviews and was a box
office bomb for Winona Ryder the 1990s
were some of her biggest years and she
starred in a number of Classics like
Edward Scissor Hands Reality Bites how
to make an American Quilt and Girl
Interrupted in the middle of those
favorites though was the 1996 third boys
a movie that was raped over the calls by
reviewers in fact her performance was
called out as a weak spot with the
Washington Post saying she was downright
miscast as a f fatal but after comments
from Ryder were published in Nigel
Good's 1998 book rowna Ryder the
biography it became clear that she knew
boys wasn't going to be very good and
actively tried to get out of making it
according to Ryder the film went through
a number of last minute script changes
that forced her to reconsider the movie
unfortunately there was really nothing
she could do her contract was signed she
had no control over script rewrite next
time I get a script for a tiny movie
I'll have to have a serious contract
drawn up saying nothing can be changed
without my approval David Cross best
known today for his role as Tobias funk
in Arrested Development that to keep
coming back to star in a series about
computer animated singing chipmunks
based on the iconic cartoon of the same
name Alvin and the Chipmunks came to
live action in 2007 and put cross into
the role of Record Company CEO Ian Hawk
and when it became a huge box office hit
cross had to return for two more even
though he hated his role in the first
movie and didn't have a good time making
it by the third he said he was downright
miserable during the Press tour for a
show the increasingly poor decisions of
Todd Margaret cross said I was
contractually obligated to do three this
last film was literally without question
the most unpleasant experience I've ever
had in my professional life it was just
a really awful unpleasant experience I
honestly don't regret it I don't there's
no shame in it I did it because I hadn't
worked for uh 6 months at that point
during the era when Hollywood was
dominated by the studio system plenty of
actors were forced to do movies they
didn't want to make most of them kept
their feelings to themselves as
professionalism seemed to demand though
some like Natalie Wood vo that his
pleasure on occasion nobody was more
outspoken about their feelings on the
system though than Olivia De havin who
was rarely afraid to express herself on
the subject the star of Classics like
Gone With the Wind and they died with
their boots on the havind was famousy
and happy with the movies that Warner
Brothers kept giving her in 1942 she was
C in the film princess oo a movie about
a European princess living Incognito in
the US the outspoken actor wanted
nothing to do with the project after
refusing to accept the leading role
Warner Brothers suspended her she
eventually relented and the film was
released a year later after that a
7-year deal with the studio ended but
Warner Brothers claimed that because of
her time spent suspended she still owed
the studio more movies in the end the
hland took Warner Brothers to court in
one of the most landmarked trials in the
history of the industry following a
lengthy and bitter trial the actor was
Victorious and together with a separate
ruling on the studio ownership of
theater chains the decision helped
abolish the studio system
forever call your men and it's the last
sound you make pirate movies were once
one of Hollywood's biggest genres but
they were long gone by the 1990s so it
probably seems like a head scratcher
when Cutthroat Island was announced a
new swashbuckling Adventure set on the
high seas at least set a couple of big
names with Michael Douglas and Gina
Davis expected to Star all that changed
however when a new script was Ed in that
nobody seemed to have liked and Douglas
abandoned ship using a loophole in his
contract regarding unexpected rewrites
the Wall Street style was replaced by
Matthew Modine who was no slouch but
certainly wasn't the big name that
Michael Douglas was though Davis too
tried to quit the film she didn't have
the same outcome that Douglas did to
make matters worse Davis was married to
the film's producer renie Harland so she
swallowed her pride and rote out the
production in the end the movie was a
disaster in theaters grossing just $10
million with a budget of $98 million
Cutthroat Island is one of the most
notorious flops in the history of
Hollywood and nearly ruined Davis's
career my job you go take care of my
little girl
now that's your job even if it was the
biggest movie of 1998 grossing a half
billion dollars Armageddon was never a
favorite of its star Bruce Willis in the
film he plays Harry Stamper an expert
driller enlisted to go into outer space
to help destroy an asteroid on a
collision course with Earth since the
movie's release Willis has really wanted
to talk about it and when he has he's
had nothing but bad things to say
especially in terms of his difficult
relationship with the movie's director
Michael Bay he once told Ain't It Cool
News few people will work with him now
and I know I will never work with him
again it was a great crew but a
screaming director does not make for a
pleasant set experience but look we were
all big boys and we got through it the
funny thing is though Willis never
wanted to work with ba in the first
place because his role as Henry stamper
in the film wasn't one he had any choice
in playing Willis's participation was
part part of a legal settlement after
another project fell apart the story
starts with Willis's involvement in the
Disney picture Broadway brawler it was a
troubled project that collapsed 20 days
into production when Willis refused to
continue making it the studio
understandably considered taking him to
court and while Disney studios's head
Joe Roth met with Willis who agreed to
star in three movies at a reduced rate
Armageddon was the only one of the three
which also included the six cense and
the kid that Willis said he outright
hated
making